hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the middle of his conclusion in
part three of his proma to any future
metaphysics Emmanuel Kant is going to
linger a bit bit over a very interesting
and for many people
compelling example or instance as it's
translated a BPI so this is something
that is supposed to illustrate for us a
point that he wants to make and what is
this point so let's check out that
paragraph before that he says that we
can never cognize beings of
understanding as they are in themselves
determinately we must assume them as
regards the sensible world and connect
them with it by reason and we can think
this connection by means of such
Concepts as Express their relation to
the world of sense so we can't avoid
thinking about these beings these Numa
that that you know are things in
themselves that we can't ever fully
cognize we can't avoid that and yet at
the same time we can't determine them
either in the way that would allow us Us
full knowledge or cognition of them so
then the he says let's think of the
concept of the highest being and this is
indeed delving into the theological idea
one of the uh ideas in the dialectic of
pure reason so the hon vasin right the
highest being Supreme Being and the
question that he begins with is how are
we actually going to cognize
what traditionally we've called Divine
attributes that is things that we can
say about determine and cons term about
this highest being and comp Begins by
saying the
deistic concept is quite a pure concept
of reason but represents only a thing
containing all realities without being
able to determine any one of them
because for that purpose an example must
be be taken from the world of sense and
he says then I should have only an
object of sense only not something quite
heterogenous something quite different
right not of the same nature uh which
can never be an object of sense so you
know this is not something that is
radically different at this point from
other conceptions of how we get to know
about God I mean there are some very
crude Notions
of God that have been bandied about you
know where God is an object of sense but
typically we see uh classical theist
saying ah you know you can't really
apply these terms they at best they're
analogical to God maybe they're even
equivocal and so we're going to come to
that in just a bit now deism was in fact
an intellectual and to some degree
practical movement as well that had some
adherence mostly among Elites but it
represents a certain conception of De of
God right and Kant is going to oppose it
to the theistic conceptions of God which
he says are a bit more robust now he
didn't coin these terms they've been
around for a while he's referencing uh
David hume's dialogues concerning
natural religion in which these terms
are used and Hume is not the originator
either they've been around for quite a
while so how do we cognize Divine
attributes Kant is going to lead us
through a short
demonstration that at least if we're in
the conscient frame of mind we really
can't say much about Divine
understanding or reason or will why not
so he says suppose I attribute to the
Supreme being understanding I have no
concept of an understanding other than
my own one that must receive its
intuitions by the senses and which is
occupied in bringing them under rules of
the unity of Consciousness so the
elements of my concept would always lie
in the appearance I should however by
the insufficiency of the appearances be
required to go beyond them to the
concept of a being so now we're talking
about the Supreme Being which neither
depends on appearances nor is bound up
with them as conditions of its
determination okay so what we've started
with is
my understanding and then we kind of
like put it on steroids as we say or
soup it up or take it to a whole another
level lots of jargon that's derived from
slanging there but I think you get the
point and now we get the Divine
understanding and then K says well wait
a second you don't have any notion of
what the hell that is why not
well he says um if I separate
understanding from sensibility to obtain
a pure understanding like what God would
have nothing remains but the mere form
of thinking without intuition by which
form alone I can cognize nothing
determinate and consequently No Object
so I would have to think another
understanding such as would Intuit its
objects but of which I have not the
least concept because the Divine the
human understanding is discursive and
can only cognize by means of general
concepts so if I want to attribute
understanding to God
very quickly I realize that if I'm going
to use the term understanding I've got
to use my understanding my my you know
concept of what understanding means for
me and whatever the hell it's going to
be in the Divine I'm not going to have
any determinate notion of that what
about reason a higher faculty okay maybe
that's a little bit more promising he
says well you know um that's not going
to work either but what if what about
will now will we understand pretty well
I mean dekart didn't he say you know
we're like God in that our Wills are
unrestricted right so Kant is going to
say I have this concept only by drawing
it from my inner experience therefore
from my dependence for satisfaction on
objects whose existence I require so the
concept rests on sensibility this is
Holy in compass
with a pure concept of the Supreme Being
not going to work right um so you know
this is going to raise some caution for
us and here he brings up Hume and he's
going to draw a strong contrast between
deism and theism now Kant says that Hume
has objections now these are strictly
speaking the objections of his
characters expressed in that that very
ingenious dialogue where all three of
them are in some respect Believers in
God but they demolish each other's
arguments and approaches for
understanding God so hume's objections
to
deism Kant is GNA say are actually weak
shock as opposed to being very strong
Zar right to
theism why well hum's objections affect
only the proofs the Bevis tumor so deis
would give Arguments for the existence
of God and Kant is saying all right Hume
is on point with that or his characters
are at least but the objections to deism
itself are are weak theism on the other
hand uh he'll talk about some cases and
that in all common cases and he says
that these objections are
irrefutable they cannot be resisted they
cannot be contradicted they cannot be
stood against you might say
right now why is this well in deism the
concept of the Supreme Being is only
Transcendent right deism is merely
Transcendent and so the determination is
it's some being that's out there beyond
our knowledge but we have to assume that
it's there why do we have to assume well
we'll see in just a moment and then he
says um theism depends on a stricter or
we might actually say narrower NE
determination of the concept of the
Supreme Being and why is this okay okay
so this is where we're going to get to
some
criticism of Hume for assuming perhaps
too much he says hum insists that the
mere concept of an original being uh to
which we must apply only ontological
predicates and what are ontological
predicates things like eternity
omnipresence omnipotence right being
everywhere uh being all powerful and he
says we think nothing
determinate properties which can yield a
concept in concetto that is in the
concrete must be super added so that is
mostly an objection to theism and then
he goes on to also add that it's not
enough to say that it's a cause we need
to explain the nature of the
causality this is something that Kant is
actually going to reject right so he
says he begins his attack on the
essential Point itself that is theism
as he had previously directed his
battery only against the proofs of deism
an attack which is not very dangerous
and its consequences all of his
dangerous arguments hume's dangerous
arguments refer to anthropomorphism and
this is actually a term that hum has his
characters use what is anthropomorphism
it is when we attribute to God things
that we understand from looking at human
beings other human beings our own
experience so for example understanding
and will we understand how those
function more or less for ourselves and
we say well God couldn't be lacking
those things God must have them but in a
super god kind of way you know and at
this point Hume would say this sort of
extrapolation this sort of analogizing
is pure
anthropomorphism and you don't have any
reason to think the Divine being is
going to be like that he actually has
his characters you know back and forth
arguing with each other how do you know
the universe wasn't created by a
committee of gods or a scile God or some
sort of giant spider you know once you
start going beyond the bounds of
experience things get really really
shaky and he says that theism is going
to be contradictory in itself if we can
abandon
anthropomorphism then theism disappears
and nothing remains uh but deism from
which nothing can come which is of no
value and which cannot serve as any
foundation to religion or morals now as
just a side note it's quite interesting
that during the French Revolution which
is coming up after uh you know David
hume's time um we are going to see
Thomas pay a deist writing a book called
uh the the a of Reason arguing that
everybody ought to be a deist precisely
because not only can it be proven
correct but it will lead to an
improvement of morals right so pain if
Pain's right Hume is wrong if hume's
right pain is is wrong and K would
actually say Well they're they're
probably both wrong when it comes down
to this so what do we mean now about
this this anthropomorphizing so K here
is going to make a really important
distinction between two kinds of
anthropomorphism how do we get there
well let's look at the next
paragraph So he tells us if we connect
with the command to avoid all
Transcendent judgments of pure reason
the command which apparently conflicts
with it to proceed to Concepts that lie
beyond the field of its imminent
empirical use we discover both of these
can subsist together but only at the
boundary
of all permitted use of reason this
boundary belongs to the field of
experience as well as to that of the
beings of thought pretty important
juncture point there right and we are
thereby taught how these remarkable
ideas serve merely for marking the
bounds of human reason on the one hand
they give warning not boundlessly to
extend cognition by experience as if
nothing but World remained for us to
cognize and yet on the other hand not to
transgress the bounds of experience and
think of the judgments of the things
Beyond them as things of themselves and
he says we stop at this boundary if we
limit our judgment merely now notice
this key idea merely to the relation
which the world may have to a being
whose very concept lies beyond all the
cognition we can attain within the world
so we've got the world we are we know
the world we live within the world we
cognize the world we're not sad
satisfied with the world we move beyond
the world not only to any old Numa or
thing in itself but to the Supreme Being
why do we do that well because there is
a relation that we're assuming there
between the Supreme Being and the world
and it is a relation of condition to
conditions or
conditioning now we don't really know
that much about the thing God that is
lying behind all of
this so he tells us we don't attribute
to the Supreme Being any of the
properties in themselves by which we
represent objects of experience thereby
we avoid dogmatic anthropomorphism this
is what K is saying theism does it
engages in dogmatic
anthropomorphism Hume agrees why because
it attributes to the Supreme Being
properties in themselves so the the
properties are real Properties by which
we represent objects
G of
experience right so
we extend things from the world to God
and we say Okay God has a will God is
eternal God pick whatever else you want
this is dogmatic
anthropomorphism is anthropomorphism
always
problematic not according to Kant
because we can have a
symbolic
anthropomorphism he says if we
attribute them the properties to his
relation to the world and allow
ourselves a symbolic
anthropomorphism which in fact concerns
language
only right not the object itself object
not
gagin so we've got two different kinds
of
anthropomorphism one is going to be
problematic the other is actually not
only not problematic it's going to be a
clue how we
proceed
right so he goes on and he says if I say
that we're compelled to consider the
world as if it were now that's an
important term there not as if is as if
it were the work of a supreme
understanding and will I really say
nothing more than that a watch a ship a
regiment Bears the same relation to the
watch maker the ship Builder and the
commanding officer as the world of sense
or whatever constitutes the substratum
of this complex of appearances does to
the unknown which I do not cognize as it
in is it in itself but as it is for me
and what does thatan mean as it is for
me in relation to the world of which I
am a part now this is what Kant is going
to call analogy
understood in its proper correct sense
so again drawing a distinction here
between what happens in theism what
happens in deism so he says such a
cognition is one of analogy and it does
not signify as is commonly understood as
most people are uh making sense of
analogy an imperfect similarity between
two things now he's going to use perfect
and imperfect uh F
un uh this has to do with completion a
term that we've seen you know throughout
this this entire work but especially in
this third part uh reason is seeking its
completion in things so this is an an
analogy and a similarity that itself is
imperfect not being brought to its
fruition not being fully developed
between two things so when we say ah
I've got Understanding God's got
understanding that's an
anthropomorphism and that is an that is
a wrong kind of analogy that's the kind
of analogy people were drawing in
classical theism and Kant is rejecting
that so what is a analogy he says it is
a perfect foma
similarity of now notice not things of
relations between two entirely
dissimilar things so it could be two
things it could be two sets of things
let's look at the example that he just
used before um if I look at the world
and I want to draw an analogy
between the Supreme Being in the world
and a watch maker and a watch well
that's an example of this kind of
analogy it doesn't really tell us it
doesn't say that God is actually a watch
maker it says that God is an ex that we
don't really know what it is what he is
what she is what blah blah blah God is
right um but we do know that it Bears a
similarity a perfect similarity of
relation to the world as the watchmaker
does to the watch so he says by means of
this
analogy we get a concept of the Supreme
Being sufficiently determined for us
though we've left out everything that
could determine it absolutely and in
itself so God remains a kind of unknown
ex a black black box so to speak or gray
box if you like or a nonbox a void as
kind has described it but we can
certainly describe the way God is
related to the world the world of our
experience and so he's going to go on
and let's run through a bit of this he
says nothing can prevent our predicating
of this being a quality through reason
with regard to the world thus uh passing
to theism without being obliged to
attribute this being the kind of reason
as a property inhering in it we're going
to reject that so instead what we're
going to say is that um reason is not
transferred as a property to the first
being but only in its relation to the
world of sense so we can avoid
anthropomorphism nothing is considered
here but the cause of the rational form
which is found everywhere in the world
and reason is attributed to the Supreme
Being so far as it contains the ground
of this rational form in the world but
according to analogy only that is so far
as this expression shows merely the
relation which the Supreme cause unknown
to us has to the world in order to
determine everything in it conformably
to reason in the highest degree now
notice what he says next we are kept
from using reason as an
attribute in order to than God but not
kept from thinking the world in such a
manner as is necessary to have the
greatest possible use of Reason within
it according to principle what do we do
then we thereby acknowledge that the
Supreme Being is quite inscrutable and
even inthink in any determinant way as
to what it is in itself so we don't
transgress we don't go further than we
should in trying to figure out what God
is the way that according to Kant theism
has done and according to Hume it's done
deism doesn't have that problem and
deism is what we're actually led
into so you know he's going to say that
the expression suited to our feeble
Concepts is that we conceive the world
as if it came regarding its existence
and its inter deter in determination
from a supreme Reason by this conception
we cognize the Constitution which
belongs to the world itself without
pretending to determine the nature of
this cause in itself and so he concludes
the difficulties which seem to oppose
theism Disappear by combining with
hume's principle not to carry the use of
Reason dogmatically beyond the field of
all possible experience this other
principle which he quite overlooked not
to consider the field of experience as
one which bounds itself in the eyes of
our reason so
long story short Hume is Right according
to Kant theism is actually incorrect
essentially an abuse of our reason deism
and symbolic anthropomorphism and
analogy not only just fine something
that we ought to be doing engaging in as
rational beings in order to bring to
completeness our own use and ends of
that faculty of
reason